So welcome.
This is going to be a
tactical webinar.
Hopefully not too technical, but
hopefully technical enough
for those who showed up.
So I'm Dan or Danny Hermes.
I like to go by Danny.
I am a member of developer
relations here at Google.
We do things like this.
We write documentation, we work
on client libraries, and
we support APIs, and listen
to external developers.
OK?
And I support commerce APIs.
In particular, the
shopping API.
So today we're talking about the
content API for shopping.
So today we're going to talk
about four main things.
One of which actually
involves code.
I didn't want to overload you
with code snippets, but it's
pretty intense at the end.
So the first is we're going to
review what's out there, the
existing resources.
Second, we're going
to just review.
A basic primer of API use for
the content API for shopping.
Third, we're going to talk about
best practices, which
actually becomes relevant when
you get to the point where
you're making requests
programmatically.
Using best practices
can be a big deal.
And fourth, we're going to
actually use a client library
to manage product data.
And I'll say this, when we get
to the fourth section, I used
Python because this slide deck
is actually hosted on Google
App Engine, and because Python
is a dynamic language.
But I'll be making requests
in the slide deck.
I will be making real requests
to a real account with a real
client library.
So if you don't use Python,
it may not be of that much
utility for you, so you may
leave then or you may just
zone out until questions.
But I just wanted everyone
to be aware of that.
But the first three sections
will be language agnostic.
So we'll be OK up until
that point.
So let's get started.
So first, a review of
existing resources.
So one thing I want everyone to
go look at if they haven't
yet, is our shiny new
documentation.
I just completed a migration
of both the content API and
search API for shopping
documentation sets.
To developers.google.com.
It's our brand new site for all
of developer relations.
People like me.
And they are shiny.
We were on code.google.com for
documentation for many years,
and now we're on
developers.google.com and it's
really awesome.
So that's where all our docs
are, it's your go to source
for any questions you have.
Also as everyone here is
probably aware, there's a
Google group, a forum
for the content API.
If you want to find it,
obviously just go to Google
Groups and search content
API for shopping.
But the link below, if you want
to save the link, if you
aren't already aware, I just
put it in the slides.
Again, going forward, you don't
have to be worried about
writing all of these down
because this is going to be
posted to YouTube.
And I will eventually publish
this slide deck so you can
also run these test requests
just like I am.
But it's in admin only mode
right now, so only I can
access the slide deck if people
saw the URL before.
So relevant to today's talk,
some resources that you should
know about are our open source
client libraries.
We have a client libraries in
Python, .NET, Java, and PHP.
So we have solutions already
made in those four languages.
So rolling your own is actually
a bad idea unless,
I'm sure Andrew Lamonica in this
talk could talk about it,
unless you have something really
complex going on, you
don't need to roll your own.
So the specifics about these.
Python it's hosted on Google
code hosting code.google.com/p
is anything on Google
code hosting.
The name of the library is
gdata-python-client as the
link shows.
The documentation have been
generated by PyDocs.
And they're hosted in
the same repository.
The same mercurial repository
that the library is hosted at
gdata-python-cli
ent.googlecode.com/hg/pydocs/.
And there's documentation there
for every class, every
module, everything within
that library.
There are samples coming soon.
I've actually just finished a
really awesome document that
does everything in this
talk and more.
And I'll be doing that for all
four client libraries.
But it's being reviewed right
now, and should be published.
PHP, again open source, again
on Google code hosting.
Unlike the Python library, the
Python library gdata Python
client is actually used for
a lot of different APIs.
I've actually written with my
predecessor Ali [? Afshar ?]
a specific library in
PHP specifically
for the content API.
The name of that library is
gshoppingcontent-php.
And there are again
auto-generated docs generated
by the PHP doc tool,
at gshoppingcontent
-php.appspot.com.
Documenting every function,
every class, et cetera.
And there is example code within
the open source project
on Google code hosting.
I'm not going to read this link,
but if you go there,
there's a tab that
says Source.
And within there, you have a
view of the actual file system
in the library.
There's an examples folder, just
click that, and you'll
have an example of pretty much
every action you'd want to
take with the API.
Next is Java.
There actually is already
an existing document for
implementing Java.
So I'll just point you to that
document developers.googl
e.com/shopping-c
ontent/developers_guide_java.
Links like that, developer's
guide Java, will show up soon
for Python, .NET, and PHP.
So it'll just be developer's
guide Python, developer's
guide .NET, developers
guide PHP.
For the Java docs, the main
thing being used it's a client
library called the Google
API Java client.
And that's part of
actually a second
generation of client libraries.
The document really goes
into detail on that.
And finally .NET.
It's something I wasn't
comfortable with when 2012
started, but I've written
a lot of C# since.
Again Google code hosting.
The library is called
google-gdata.
There are auto-generated
docs at
google-gdata.googlecode.com,
et cetera.
Please don't memorize it.
And there are examples code
at these two links.
The links were way too long to
actually put in here so just
goo.gl/Hei6q and goo.gl/aUxa1.
And those links the first one,
the HEI, contains a sample for
doing operations on items, which
is what we're going to
talk about today.
Actually updating your
product data.
And the second one
is for managing
multi-client accounts.
Which I know some people in
here actually manage.
Others may not worry about it.
If you don't worry about it,
obviously you don't need to
take a look at it.
So the next step is a review.
A primer on using the API.
I'm going to keep this short.
These are some borrowed slides
from some other slide decks,
but I just want to get us in the
mood for talking about API
requests, right?
So if you're inserting a
product, this is pretty much
what it looks like.
You have an Atom entry holding
the product data.
And the data is formatted as
XML, obviously so it can be
machine readable.
And we have things like Title,
which is in the Atom name
space content, which provides
a description.
And then custom elements from
our own Name Spaces, Names
Spaces specific to the content
API, like the ID to describe
your product, the condition
of your
product, price, et cetera.
So once you have this, you post
this XML payload to have
specific endpoint.
And this endpoint, you see it
at the top here in the green
POST,
https://content.googleapis.com et cetera.
And this is a specified link,
which we'll talk about in two
slides actually, that you
can make requests to.
And the third line of this
little code snippet, you see
an authorization header.
You're going to need to send
an authorization token and
we'll talk about how
you can get that
with the client library.
And how you can abstract away
the authentication process.
So if it succeeds, you
get a 201 response.
If you insert an item, and it's
been inserted correctly,
you'll get a 201 with some
various header data.
One of which is location.
So the second to bottom row
here, you see this location,
content.googleapis.com,
blah, blah, blah.
It includes a dummy account
ID for the merchant.
And then at the very end you
have a unique identifier.
And this is why it's called
location, a unique identifier
for the product.
And that's we're going to talk
about in the next slide.
So this unique URL for each
product is actually going to
be used when you make,
update, and delete
requests for the product.
So it's very important
to keep track of.
And this location is composed
of a few big
pieces to think of.
So the first big piece
is the Root.
The Root is https://content.
googleapis.com/content/V1, for
version one.
The second part, obviously
your item is yours.
So it has to be your Merchant ID
to be able to associate the
product with your account.
The next is the Path.
So for items, the path
is /items/products.
But as people may know, there
are other operations that can
be performed with
the Content API.
So there are other paths.
There's a managed accounts
path, for MCA operations.
There's a data feeds path for
data sheet operations.
And there may be more paths
as the Content API grows.
The next thing is
a Projection.
We have two, generic
and schema.
Not really going to get
into that today.
And then the last one, like
I said, is the Product ID.
And that is a string
of four values,
delimited with a colon.
The first of which
is a channel,
either online or local.
The second of which is the
language for the product.
Here it's English.
The third of which is the
country for the product, here
US for the United States.
And fourth, the unique
ID that you actually
set in the SCID element.
So here's it's SKU123.
And other than sending back
the location and a 201
response, you're actually
getting a body with the same
information you sent.
So you have the same content
language, the same title, the
same content, et cetera.
And you're getting
back new things.
So you have a published element,
you have an edited
element, you have an expiration
date, which has
been set by the API.
So it's all these things
and more are
returned in the API response.
And one last part, actually, two
more things in the primer.
First batch operations.
I highly encourage it.
We'll talk about a lot today.
But batch operations, for those
who don't know, allow
you to put multiple
products and
operations in the same requests.
So you can delete one product
and insert another product in
the same exact request. Not
different requests for
different operations, but
the same request.
There is a 1 meg cap on each
request, but we do allow
compressed requests.
So you can GZIP or use some
other compression method to
make your request smaller, and
hence fit more products and
more operations into the same
batch request. From a batch
request, you don't just get one
single batch response that
says good job or bad job.
You get individualized responses
for each operation
you attempt to perform.
And by the same token, you get
individualized errors for each
request that errored out.
This is pretty helpful,
especially when you put this
next to using data feeds, where
you just have a mass
email after the fact.
This is a great way to
understand what has worked,
what hasn't worked, and act
on it almost instantly.
So finally, the great part of
using batch requests is that
you save on the number
of requests.
And this is a picture I really
like to use, so please keep it
in mind when you're
thinking about
using individual requests.
The great thing about mass
requests is you take products
and operations, you bundle them
all into one request, and
you just send it away
with the POST. OK?
And so the last thing I wanted
to review is special modes.
So one of them is
dry run mode.
Dry run mode actually allows you
to test out your request
before you actually make real
changes to your inventory.
So you can test out an insert
without actually inserting the
products you're testing.
By doing so, the responses,
the errors, the warnings,
everything you would expect to
get back, will actually be
returned in that request. But
nothing happened in your
actual inventory.
The API receives the request,
it does all the usual things
it would do, and doesn't inject
the item into our
database, but it does do
everything else it would do.
So you can enable this by
simply adding a small
parameters, the dry run
parameter to the end of your
query string.
Like I said, it's available
for any state changing
operation, inserts,
updates, deletes.
And this is what
it looks like.
You make a POST request. So here
would be a POST request
for an insert.
You have your Root, you
have your account ID.
You have your path, you
have your projection.
And then the second line is just
a question mark to start
your query parameter,
and then dry run.
So how do some of these apply
to best practices?
So best practices doc, we
actually just launched about
two or three weeks ago.
I highly encourage people
to read it.
It's on our documentation.
I don't know, the link maybe
a little small there
for people to see.
I'll get it bigger
for a second.
There it is. developers.googl
e.com/shopping-c
ontent/getting-s
tarted/best-practices.
And there are really five best
practices to keep in mind.
And I'll go into detail about
them in the following slides.
But first, don't use the API
like you're using Feeds.
Second don't mix Feeds
and the API.
Third, update items as
soon as they change.
Forth, make sure to update
items before they expire.
That's actually different from
as soon as they change, and
we'll go into details on that.
And fifth, combine updates
into batch requests
whenever you can.
This really relates the stuff
I talked about before.
So first, don't use APIs
as you would Feeds.
Why not?
Well when you're using Feeds
you send an update of your
entire Feed every day.
If 10% of your inventory has
changed, you send 100% of your
inventory every day.
But that's a waste.
That's a waste of our space,
it's a waste of your space,
and it's a waste of
processing power.
So you only need to update the
items that are changing.
Sending your entire
Feed, like I said,
consumes time and resources.
And it's just not worth it.
Rather than sending 100%, you
can just send that 10% that
has changed.
And the other 90% won't
be affected.
It won't go away, nothing
bad will happen.
That's the great part
about the API.
So the second part, don't have
a whole lot on the slide.
Don't mix Base Feeds with
the Content API.
This is actually something
that's been discussed on the
forum, and I know one of the
attendees may or may not do
this, but the thing about mixing
the Base Feeds and the
Content API is there's a lot
of undefined behavior.
If you're making updates on a
Feed and also updates with the
API there are race conditions.
You have two updates racing to
the database, and you may
think one's going to get
there first, but you
don't actually know.
The behavior is undefined.
Another issue, if you insert an
item with the API, but you
decide you want to delete it
with a Feed, you actually
can't do it.
So way too much undefined
behavior.
There's a lot of other things
other than those two examples,
but just don't mix them.
If you're going to switch to the
Content API, then please
switch to the Content API.
Don't straddle the
river in between.
But if people have other
opinions and things like that,
we can discuss them
after the webinar.
The third thing, update items
as soon as they change.
This obviously insures your data
on Google Product Search
is as fresh as possible.
And everyone wants that.
So rather than doing four big
Feeds updates every day, or
two or one or however you're
doing it with Feeds, or used
to doing it with Feeds, you can
set an update the second
the item has changed.
This makes things super fresh.
It also keeps a log jam of
requests and updates the need
to be made from building up.
If you send a request the second
it needs to be sent,
then you don't have to add
to any queue of requests.
Fourth thing, make
sure to update
items before they expire.
So this is a bit different
than the update items the
second they change.
So by default, items
expire in 30 days.
If you don't send any expiration
date with your
product, it will be tacked on an
expiration date 30 days in
the future from your request.
And you can't extend it beyond
30 days, that's the maximum
the API allows.
So if you don't change an item
over the period, it'll expire.
Let's say, 50% of your inventory
changes all the
time, and the other 50% seldom
changes on the order of three
or four times a year.
But certainly not
every 30 days.
Well that 50%, if you don't
touch it after the initial
insertion of that inventory,
will expire in 30 days.
And you don't want that, you
want your inventory to be
around, to show up in Google
Product Search.
So to avoid expiration, you can
send, in quotes, "Empty
Updates." So Empty Updates
would be an update of the
product without actually any
changes to the product.
So you can make a Get request,
get all the product data from
the API, and then just send it
right back with an update
request. Except don't send
the expiration date.
You can either manually have an
expiration date 30 days in
the future, or you can just get
rid of the expiration date
element, and have the API,
again by default, set an
expiration date 30 days
in the future.
So if you did this once a month,
then we would be back
in the Data Feeds mindset.
And we don't want to be there.
So don't do it all at once,
spread the load.
One approach that I like is pick
a fixed number of days.
Preferably something
that divides 30.
And use that as your horizon.
So let's say all my products
that expire in five days, then
I'm going to update them.
I'll send an empty update so
they don't expire, and now I
have a 30 day window.
And then five days later, I'll
do that for the items that
expire five days from then.
But there are other ways
you can do it.
Really, be creative.
It has to obviously depend on
your own data, on your own
inventory, and the frequency
of your own updates.
But again, don't do it all
once, spread the load.
And the last best practice I
want to talk about before we
get super technical and super
Python, is that, hopefully
this is a no brainer, but
combine updates into batch
requests whenever you can.
This gives you better
performance, gives us better
performance.
And it allows you to update more
items with your request.
Obviously it saves time,
and a lot of
times, it can save space.
And another great thing that
it saves is your quota.
You do have a quota limit on a
lot of different things, and
this can actually use
less of your quota.
I know a lot of people don't
have a lot of experience with
this, but it actually
can be relevant.
I mentioned before, the third
best practice I believe,
update items as soon
as they change.
Well, if you only have, let's
say, one change every minute,
or one change every five
minutes, that's fine.
Just send that change.
But if you're getting up to
five, six, seven, eight
changes a minute, it may be
better to hold off and wait
until you get a few piling up
and then send a batch request.
And I'm sure there are folks,
even in this particular
hangout who have experienced
similar situations.
So finally, for the fourth
section, using a client
library to manage your
product data.
Like I said before, we're
going to be talking
specifically about Python.
But one of the great things
about Python is that it pretty
much reads like pseudo code.
So a lot of the things you're
going to see, whether you
understand Python or not, you'll
be able to understand
as general programming
concepts.
Which hopefully makes this
visible by Python experts and
non-experts alike.
But if you'd like to zone
out, feel free.
So the first thing I'll talk
about is installation.
Like I said, it's hosted
on Google code hosting.
If you go there, you click
downloads at the very top.
There's a download, just
a ZIP of the entire
contents of the library.
So download it somewhere, unzip
it somewhere in your
directory choice.
Once you've un-zipped it, if
you're on a Mac or you're on
Linux, cd into that directory.
If you're on Windows, dir
into that directory.
And run python setup.py
install.
That's it, it's installed.
The first thing we're going to
talk about as authentication.
Now remember, every request
you send needs to be
authenticated.
You need to send an auth token
in the header of your request.
And this can kind
of be a pain.
But the great thing about these
client libraries is they
allow you to authentication,
they allow you to include your
auth token without worrying
about any of that.
They abstract away everything,
so we can really just deal
with the product data.
That's really what
we want to do.
We want to deal with the product
data, and the way
we're operating on
our product data.
Everything else let somebody
deal with.
Like I said, this is a pre-made
solution so you don't
have to roll your own.
So all requests of the content
API obviously need to be
authenticated.
So here we're going to use
what's called programmatic
login, or client login to get
a token that can be sent in
the header.
A token is obtained from client
login just by making a
POST request to google.com/accou
nts/clientlogin.
And the body of that request
needs to have a few things.
In the green, at the bottom,
you need to send your email
address, your password.
You need to send the service
you're authenticating again.
So here the service is called
structured content, and then
you need to send a fourth a
property called source.
And the source property
is really
just for logging purposes.
It just identifies your
application in some way.
But it's not really
tied to anything.
So you can call it whatever
you want.
Here we call it the Content
API webinar source.
So let's see some Python, and
actually execute a request to
client login and get ourselves
an auth token.
So first, we're going
to import a module.
So this module, gdata.contentfor
shopping.client, is going to
do all the work for us.
So it's a module in
the gdata library.
It's specific to content for
shopping, and it's the client
part of the content for
shopping module.
Now we're also going to use
a data part of that.
And those are the two prongs
that do all the work for us,
and abstract away all the hard
programming parts that we may
have to worry about.
So first we're going to set up
our email, our password and
our application name.
Which is equivalent
to the source.
Email, fake email,
password, fake
passport, application name.
They're just strings.
And next we're going to
instantiate a client object.
So the client object is going
to be an instance of the
content for shopping client
class, which comes from the
gdata.contentforshopping.client
module.
So we instantiate a class
object, and then we use the
object to make our request.
client.ClientLogin is the method.
And we're sending our
email, our password,
our application name.
And then we also send the
service that we're
authenticating against. And
again, like I said, the
service here is structured
content.
Structured content is actually
what the API was originally
named, and that's why you see
CS as the shorthand for the
name space as well.
Anyhow, let's make the request.
I'm going to click
execute code, and will actually
make a request to
client login and give
me an auth token.
So there it is.
So there's my auth token.
As you can see, it's a
gdata.gauth.ClientLogInToken object.
And not going to provide the
whole thing, I whited out the
last about 90%.
But I actually have a token
string on this object, which
is typical for what you receive
from client login.
So remember what your
requests look like.
You have all this jumbled XML
with various attributes, some
of which come from different
name spaces.
So we're going to build this
with Python, and I just wanted
to remind you what it looks
like, so some of the things we
do on the next slide make
a bit of sense.
So title and content come
from the main name
space, which is Atom.
Whereas ID condition price come
from name spaces specific
to the content API for shop.
So let's create a product.
Excuse So first we're going
to have our imports.
Import CGI is actually
commented out.
There's going to be a reason
for that, I'll
explain it in a bit.
Then I'm going to just
import two modules.
The first atom.data.
This is a general data module
for all gdata APIs that are
using the name space.
So title and content, as well
link, are coming from this
name space.
So that's where we're
going to use it.
And then the other one, which
I mentioned before, is
gdata.contentforshopping.data.
This holds all the custom
data classes that we
used for this API.
And it's a really, really long
string to keep putting on
every line of the slide, so I'm
just aliasing as CFS_data.
CFS for content for shopping.
So when you see CFs_data, I'm
really talking about the data
module for the content
for shop.
So we start off with a product
entry, an empty product entry.
And recall entry is the name
of the atom element which
holds all the product data.
So CFS_data.ProductEntry() is
what we start with for our
empty product.
Now first we want
to set title.
So to set title, we just set
the title attribute on the
entry with one of these custom
data classes from the
atom.data module.
Atom.data.title with a
string for the title.
So it's 32 gigabyte
MP3 player.
Similarly we set the content,
oh my gosh, it holds so much
music, 32 gigs.
And finally, we're going to
use the link part of the
atom.data module to set the
actual product link.
So to set the product link,
you're going to use a
Link(rel="alternative") link,
and here we can use Python
keyword arguments rel, type and
href, to actually build
this custom link attribute.
And instead of actually
directly setting the
entry.link attribute, as we did
with title and content,
we're actually appending to a
list. Since there could be
more links, there can also be
rel=edit, rel=cell, rel=next,
things like that.
We only are appending to a
list of links rather than
directly setting the link.
So now for the custom attributes
specific to the
content API for shopping.
They're all pretty similar,
so I'm going to go
through this quickly.
But the first one, we directly
set the product ID attribute
to CFS_data.ProductID and then
we just use a string for the
product ID.
Price, very similar, and as
with the link, we actually
have an XML attribute unit,
on the price XML element.
So we use the Python keyword
unit to actually
specify that attribute.
And the rest proceeds
similarly.
One last comment I wanted to
make, with Google product
category, you have these greater
than signs to go to a
more specific category.
And some of these
have ampersands.
So typically, when you send XML
that has a greater than
sign, you need to
XML escape it.
So instead of a greater than
sign, you use &gt:.
Similar ampersand needs to
be escaped as &amp:.
In Python, you would do that
with CGI.escape, you just put
the string in there, and
it escapes it for XML.
However, you just need to worry
about data here, you
don't need to do any of that,
because the client library
does all that for you.
It escapes it into everything
it should be escaped for.
And you just worry about,
like I said, the data.
OK.
So that might have been
a bit of a whirlwind.
There are a lot of attributes.
That's one of the most confusing
things about the
content API for shopping.
So there is documentation
for it.
I'm not going to read this link
at the bottom, but this
is a snapshot of the
auto-generated PyDocs
Everything is in there, every
class, every attribute, the
way to use them,
it's all there.
So if you're curious,
go take a look.
We have similar stuff for the
other languages as well, as I
showed in the resources
section.
So now let's actually do
something with this client
object that we've authenticated
with.
So we're going to retrieve all
of our items first. The reason
I'm doing this before I'm
inserting a product, after I
just showed you how to make a
product, is to show you that I
don't have any items at
all in my account.
So to retrieve your list of
items recall, you just make a
GET request to the
item's feed.
So it has the route URI, your
account ID, the path, which is
item's products, and
then generic.
So the first thing we do, we
specify an account ID>.
My account ID is not actually
1234567, but I'm not going to
expose it here for
obvious reasons.
So it's as simple as making
one call to the client.
So you do have your client
object, we instantiated it a
few slides back.
It's a member of the concept
for shopping client class.
And all we need to send
is our account ID.
The reason we send our account
ID is so it can actually
construct the URI to make
the request to.
And then we send the auth token
that we retrieved, so it
can sign the request with
the auth token.
So the API knows who we are,
so it doesn't just give
anybody our products.
And it's going to return
a feed object.
But this feed object is
parsed by the API.
We don't have to worry about
parsing some hairy XML string,
it's already done by
the client library.
Magic.
So within an atom feed element,
the products are just
a list of XML entry elements.
So we have a product list from
the fee.entry attribute.
And this next bit of Python
code is not exactly pseudo
code, but what I'm saying is, if
the list is not empty, then
let's print for every product
in the list, lets print the
title of the product, otherwise
print no product.
So since I have no data right
now in my account, I'm
expecting no products,
but who knows.
No products.
OK, great.
So I actually literally made a
request with my auth token and
my account ID to the API.
Had it parsed by the library,
and returned an empty product
list. Just like that.
So the next thing we're going to
do with the product we just
created is insert an item.
So to insert an item, instead of
making a GET, request it's
a POST request to
the item's feed.
It's the exact same URL that you
made a GET request to, but
this time you're going to send
an XML payload with the
product data.
But the library does
all that for you.
So the response, also as a
refresher, will contain
everything you inserted, plus
any errors that occurred, plus
things that changed.
Like app edited, published,
things like that.
So the first thing we do, we
create an empty product, then
dot dot dot.
You fill it up with whatever
data you want to put it.
And I am using the example
with the 32
gigabyte MP3 player.
So just as with GET products,
it's a simple call with a
single method on the client.
Client.InsertProduct, you have
this product that you've
created, this custom product
class, you send your account
ID to create the URI, and you
send your auth token to sign
the request. So let's make the
request and print out the
title of what we've inserted.
Waiting.
OK, great.
So now the 32 gig MP3 player
has been inserted.
So I was kind of willy-nilly
there, and
didn't worry about errors.
So a quick note, we're not going
to actually worry about
errors in this presentation.
But in the documentation
there are plenty of
examples using errors.
But if you were hoping to catch
errors, there's a custom
class called
gdata.client.RequestError.
And you can use a try/except
block to catch these errors.
So first you'd import
gdata.client.
You would try to insert the
product as we did in the
previous code slide, and then
you would catch the error sent
by this request. The client is
actually going to throw a
request error.
And then the request error is
going to be a typical HTTP
response object.
It's going to have the headers,
it's going to have
the URI, and it's going
to have the body.
So you can actually access the
error response from the
exception.body.
So you're catching the request
error, you're aliasing it as
the variable exception, and
then you can get the error
response from exception.body,
the body
attribute on the exception.
So that's it for errors,
but that's
something to keep in mind.
So I showed you how to retrieve
all your products,
but how do you retrieve
a specific product?
So recall that an item's
location is based on a
specific product ID.
So you have the route URI, your
account ID, a path, a
projection, and then the
specific product ID, which is
a colon delimited string made
up of channel, language,
country, and ID.
So rather than make you build
all that and worry about
making the request, the library
really just needs
product ID, country,
and language.
So you can also specify the
channel, but the majority of
products are online, so if the
channel is online, you don't
need to worry about it.
So to get the specific product,
you make a similar
request as before, but instead
of sending a product object,
we're sending these string's
product ID, country, language,
and of course, account
ID, and auth token.
So let's make this request. I
made SKU123 the ID for my 32
gig player.
So let's see if we can
actually retrieve it.
So if all goes well, we should
see that it's been retrieved.
Wonderful.
So it's that simple to retrieve
a specific product
via the client library.
So now that we've retrieved
it, what if you
want to update it?
With the API, you can set an
update request directly to the
unique URL for the product.
And you just re-send the product
payload as XML but you
have some edits.
So let's say we want to
change the title.
So I change the title to
32 gig MP3 player with
headphones.
I obviously would probably want
to change the description
and maybe the price and some
other things, but let's say
I'm just changing the title.
So once you change everything
you want to change, call the
update product method
on the client, and
let's see what happens.
I'm actually going
to execute this.
So we have new data in the
product, and the new title, 32
gigabyte MP3 player
with headphones.
And finally one last thing
we're going to do on
individual products, before
we move on to
batching, is deletes.
So let's assume we have
this product in hand.
You make a request to the same
unique URL, but instead of a
PUT request, you make a DELETE
request to delete the item.
So one thing that I actually
forgot to mention, when you're
getting the product before
you're updating, if you want
to update, you can build the
product the exact same way you
inserted it.
However, you need the unique
URL, and so if you see the
arguments product, account ID,
and auth token to delete
products, you don't see the
unique URL anywhere.
Well under the covers, what's
happening is the method is
inspecting the product object.
And it's finding the
rel=edit link.
The rel=edit link is actually
what holds the unique URL.
So if you're going to build a
product from scratch before
deleting or before updating,
you need to
include a rel=edit link.
If on the other hand, you do is
we did, you just retrieve
it, then the API will return the
rel=edit link, and you'll
be all good.
You'll be copacetic.
So when you delete, you don't
get a product object back.
So there's no title that you
receive, and there isn't even
a body to the response.
But there is a HTTP code
on the response, and a
reason for the code.
So let's delete, and let's hope
we get 200, which means
all good on the request.
So cool.
So our status is 200, and
our reason is OK.
So are our delete response
succeeded.
So one last thing before I go
into batching are these custom
parameters like warnings
and dry run.
It's as simple as specifying
a Python keyword parameter.
In .NET, it's similar.
.NET you're setting an attribute
on a query object,
but it's pretty similar
to this.
PHP it's also a keyword
argument.
I don't know off the top off my
head how it's done in Java.
But it's specified in all
four implementations.
So you just make your request.
So whatever your operation is,
insert, update, delete.
On the products, you send
the product, the
account ID, and the token.
And if you want to include the
dry run or warnings query
parameters, you just said
dry run to true
or warnings to true.
These are, like I said, keyword
parameters in Python
which default to false if
they're not included, and when
they're false, the parameter's
not added.
It's just left alone.
And it's that simple.
Onto batching.
This is the last thing I'm
going to talk about.
If people do want to hear about
multi-client accounts
and things like that, it is
enabled within the library.
I just didn't want to go
on forever and ever.
And I'd be happy to answer
questions after I'm done.
So to execute a batch request,
every request is
going to the same URI.
This URI is the root URI, the
account ID, the path, items,
products, the projection
schema.
And then instead of a unique ID
for a product, you're just
posting to batch.
You could also use warnings
and dry run with batch, so
keep that in mind.
But this does make the API not
completely restful because you
can actually send updates and
deletes and other things all
in the same requests, which is
not really how rest works.
But enough of that.
So what you're going to send in
a batch request is the same
thing you received when you got
all of your products, and
that is an atom feed
XML element.
And the products in that feed
element are going to be a list
of atom entries.
And in order to include them in
a batch request, you need
to actually include
a batch operation.
So for the inserts,
<batch:operation
type="insert">, for the deletes,
type="delete">.
Et cetera, you get it.
And a few other things, like I
said, for delete and update on
the individual request,
you need the
rel=edit for them to succeed.
Well that's true for update
request, but for delete
requests, you actually need to
set atom ID element with that
unique URL for the product.
And actually batch deletes,
you don't need any of the
other product data, you just
need <batch:operation
type="delete"> and
you need that ID.
Because as a parallel to
the single request,
what we really using?
We're really using the URI.
And the fact that we're deleting
comes from the HTTP
verb delete.
Whereas here, since we're in a
batch request, we need another
way to specify that verb, but
we really only needed those
two pieces.
So let's do a batch insert.
So product one is some
new product.
We're going to say it's
32 gig MP3 player.
Product two, some
other product.
It has 64 gigs, so it has some
other specs, different price,
different description,
et cetera.
So we throw those into a Python
list. Product one and
product two into a list. And
we just use that to make a
request like we were doing
before with single products.
And wrapping them up as entries
into a feed element,
holding all the entries, is just
done under the covers by
the client library.
And this is essentially how
it's done with all four
implementations.
So we get a feed back by calling
insert products on the
client with this products list.
And again, obviously we
need the account ID to
construct the URI.
And we need a token to sign the
request. So let's make the
request, and print the title of
everything that's been inserted.
Just to make sure
this code works.
So this is actually
running this code.
Great.
So they've been inserted.
So what if we want to update?
So like I said before, when
you're making updates and
you're making deletes, you
need the rel=edit link.
So you can either construct it
yourself, or you can use
client.product or some other
method to somehow
obtain these products.
So let's say we already have
everything set that
we need to be set.
And let's update them.
So the first product, we're
going to make the same edit we
made in the previous slide.
We're just going to add
headphones to the product.
In the second one, we're
going to add five
gigs of free music.
Great.
From there, it's pretty
much exactly like the
client.InsertProducts call.
You throw the products into
a list, and you call
UpdateProducts.
So let's execute this and
make sure it works.
That took a little longer.
Fantastic.
So our request works, everything
is awesome.
In the Merchant Center,
your products have
been completely updated.
So I want to do side channel
check, just to make sure that
the updates are actually
going through.
We're just going to do a quick
retrieve of all my items. So
we've already done this before,
many slides ago.
I'm not going to repeat
what's happening.
Essentially, we call, get
products, and we print out the
list of all our products.
The time we executed before,
there were no products.
But let's see what's in our
inventory irrespective of an
insert or update request.
Here we have it, the titles
we expect to have. Great.
And the last batch operation
which you
can make is a delete.
Similarly as with updates, you
need to somehow obtain the
products, but like I said
before, you really only need
to set the atom ID and
the batch operation.
And setting the batch operation
is done under the
covers by InsertProducts,
by DeleteProducts, by
UpdateProducts.
So you don't even need
to worry about that.
You really just need to worry
about setting the atom ID.
So that's what the first two
lines are going to do here.
So we're going to explicitly set
the ID attribute on each
product with an atom.data.Id
object that uses hyper ref
from the edit link
of the product.
So product1.get_edit_link, it's
a method that just spits
out the edit link.
And then we're going to use the
ref string attribute to
actually recover the string of
the unique URL describing
product one.
Similarly for product two, we
do the exact same thing,
except we're calling
product2.get_edit_link instead
of product one.
And just like with updates and
inserts, we're throwing them
into a list and sending
it off.
So again, as with the individual
deletes, we don't
really care about the product
data, but we get it.
But we would like to know
the batch status.
We want to know if we got a 200,
and we want to know if we
didn't, what the reason
is that we didn't.
So let's delete these.
Awesome.
200 success on both of them.
So they're both deleted.
And then finally one last
retrieval of all my products
to make sure nothing
is in there.
There's nothing in there.
OK.
That's it.
Thank you for watching this.
Thank you for coming.